what's like the common factor out of all of us here
uh gamers yeah but like what else what what else are do we
all have in common um money and
but everybody has money in like some way or form right so
like that's not really a good comparison because that's
that's like comparing us to chat because we all have money
but what makes us different from chat we're all like living
breathing yeah but chat's living and breathing yeah no
they're not chat isn't real oh shit you're right me and my
Okay, but like what else like don't you have something that
we also have No, don't you don't you we have a we have
different things Don't you have that you know that add
particularly animate like thing in your folders Think so
Don't you mean a gaslight right now don't you mean like you
know, you know did you have like a vtuber model share for
that you that you streamed like oh really can you try like
pull up like clips of you using that unfortunately
unfortunately it's not tuesday so oh so so you do have a
vtuber model no vtubers aren't real so then what's the
tuesday thing Yes, it's not Tuesday.
Yeah, but what is the Tuesday thing?
Every Tuesday.
I don't know.
What is it?
Can you please elaborate?
It happens when Tuesday stays on Tuesday.
It happens on Tuesday stays on Tuesday.
So if I ask you again on Tuesday, would you tell me what...
Would you say what it is?
No, I'd say, fuck you, bitch.
Okay.
also anyway i'm live now as well are you live as well sure
for yeah okay all right also hello everybody welcome to the
party animals twitch rivals team we went straight into no
introduction whatsoever just like how we do our twitch
rivals anyway this is my team ditto sure for and brie
thought that like some of them had party animals experience
as in like a lot of party animals experience and that's why
I recruited 7.3 hours did you do several tournaments you did
like two twitch rival tournament no not twitch rivals but
you did two like party animals tournaments how what did you
guys do how well did you guys do team through oh it's teams
so what's your placement I don't remember all I remember is
the murder crumpets team had a mute that like played the
game 24 7 and then like what the fuck they soloed the team
they so they like destroyed so they destroyed you got
destroyed by a mute I didn't get you got but you said
destroyed the team yeah it's a team game yeah but so you're
part of the team so you got destroyed with the team yeah so
you got destroyed so you're not a god gamer you know there's
percentages like efforts in the team and what's your
percentage i'm like 90 you're like oh you were 90 of the
team yeah so you're the mute destroyed 90 of the team okay
yeah yeah but if you're 90 of the team and the mute
destroyed your team, you got destroyed by the mute.
Okay, listen, I was like 60% in the PAL world team.
I was like 60 to 80 in the PAL world team, too.
I want to be hearing this.
What do you mean?
In PAL world, we all did an equal contribution to the team.
I quote, Surefore, you have to carry us.
You're the carry.
Brutal.
Yeah, and you don't.
to a fucking bug i can't that can't be controlled all i'm
saying is if you didn't die to that bug we could have got
third place yeah well maybe if you made me more pokeballs oh
yeah yeah we made you a collection of pokeballs what do you
mean more of a collection you you did not need it you did it
was not the power balls that was the issue here it was i i
had the clutch out with like minimum power balls i'd be
glorifying my bro oh my god you what he was glorifying my
shit oh okay yeah i just i just want to make sure i heard
correctly thank you okay yeah you know glorp glorp northon
no yeah glorb little cat little green cat with antennas oh
you're talking about the cast thinking about that sponge bob
rapper no i'm talking about Glorp.
Glorp?
What the fuck is Glorp?
Oh, there's Glorp.
Oh, my god!
Wait, he's so cute!
Yeah, he's Glorping.
Oh, yeah, he's Glorp, but that makes sense.
Yeah.
There's, there's Yelorp, and there's Orlorp.
Basically, there's a color forever orb.
There's a color for every orb?
Wait, what are the orbs?
Well, there's like Glorp, and that's blue.
And then, and then what?
This.
Wharp, I have to look.
He has to look.
You don't know them by heart?
Now, I only have Glorp.
Glorp looks like a Neopet.
I love him.
Glorp, cat.
Basically, the beginning letter is the color.
Oh!
Glorp is Glorp because it's green.
Is there Yorp?
Yorp?
There might be.
There's no Yorp.
There's no yellow.
There's no yellow cat.
There's blue.
Is there a blue?
No, there isn't.
There's blue.
Oh, there's blue.
see any i think this is a myth i think only glorp no it's
real i only see glorp there's no proof you only see what you
want to see oh and then where's the where the fuck is yorp
where's you looking for him i'm looking yeah you can't find
him no i can where's yorp yeah he's gaslighting
Here's y'allorp.
Where is it?
Post it in a Team 3 chat.
My Team 3 team don't you forget?
There we go.
How am I on it?
Wait, there is y'allorp.
Oh my god.
Wait, how did you find y'all?
My chat helped me.
Oh, so you didn't do any of the work.
I got helpers.
So you didn't do any of the work.
You ever heard of a community?
It's a community effort.
Wait, I thought chat wasn't real.
How are they helping you?
Chat isn't real.
You know like schizophrenics where they have like voices in
their head?
What's that?
So the voices in your head help you.
Oh,
we're getting pinged for stuff now.
Okay, nice.
Who are we?
It's time.
It's time to find the lobby.
Please be careful.
Does this hide the code when we join it?
I have no idea.
I'm gonna fucking hide my game screen first.
I don't know.
Oh, I joined a random game.
Okay, custom game.
And then you search it up.
Search.
What time is it over there for you?
Ditto.
Ditto, what time is it?
It's for aim.
Oh no!
She's locked in.
I can find it, Bobby.
Maybe it's not up yet.
Oh no, it's up.
I'm in.
Oh, I can see it?
You saw?
I got it.
I would join Doiky then.
Yeah, yeah.
Join me.
I'm in.
Also, it does show the code.
Oh, Doiky, you're on online.
Oh, I'll invite you in.
Let me see.
Okay.
Let's see.
Where are you?
Oh, I can't.
Give me a sec.
Let me see if I can invite you.
Oh, my friend.
Oh, I need to like invite.
I need to add you in this.
Oh, wait, no.
I got you.
Okay.
I sent you in.
Do you get it?
Are you pussy slayer?
Yeah.
Is that...
Is that a pussy slayer?
Yeah.
He's pussy slayer, by the way.
Oh my god.
He's here to...
He's here to slay some cats.
I'm not thinking I would be in Twitch rivals.
It's okay.
We're so locked in.
I was watching Drops team.
fucking scrimming you they were scrimming party animals not
for like two weeks two to three weeks why didn't you set up
scrims like why did i not set up would you join would you
actually join scrims if i set it up would you though sure
for yeah i'll take that as a no i'm always down for scrim
Yeah, I don't think you would fucking scrim party animals.
But yeah, I was watching fucking a drop with the full-on
Apex roster screaming at party animals and hard-comming.
It was actually crazy.
Apex players are sweats.
Wait, what's the comparison between...
What about Apex versus Overwatch?
Who's sweatier?
Apex?
I think Overwatch tries to be sweatier, but it just comes
across more depressing.
shit is that true as an overwatch player yeah we've gone
through enough one tricks that never swapped that we just
we've become complacent with everything that's so true
that's so i was the one trick so you know you were the
problem i was in mercy main oh you were part of the problem
you were 100 i would avoid it you i avoided you and avoided
you No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Do you know what the game mode is?
It's Lollipop Factory.
Lollipop, yeah.
Yeah, so I'm wearing you.
You collect the sheet.
Yeah, and then you have to move it to, like, a little tray,
and then you have to pull the lever to put the tray in.
And then there's, like, a big gummy bear that's worth, like,
way more.
Yeah, I'm just going to be beating the shit out of that.
Okay, okay, so, like, what's the strat for this?
I remember when I tried to play this, and I got...
Absolutely destroyed.
You have people trying to stop them from putting in candy
and then you have people on your team putting the candy and
I'm gonna be interference.
Okay.
I'm just gonna be beating the shit.
Okay, I'll help bring candy over.
You gotta protect me.
They don't and I will bring candy over.
I don't know what Bree's gonna do.
Oh, I will beat people up.
Okay.
Are you good at beating people up?
Yes.
Okay, okay.
And you're not lying to me like how you lied earlier.
I would never.
I will protect you.
I'm indiscriminate in my beating.
All right.
Wait, no, you're not supposed to beat us up.
You're part of the team.
Yeah, wait.
If I have an AoE weapon, you guys are caught in the
crossfire.
There's nothing I can do about it.
Then we lose.
You know what?
That's fair.
I thought you want to win.
Hey, listen.
If I have the lollipop sick...
This is just party animals.
This is serious.
You just...
There's AoE.
You just gotta take it serious.
I'm serious.
But you're a gamer.
that's why i'm forewarning at the beginning but you're a
gamer you should be able to like control the beatings no
listen i can't control the actions of my teammates i can
only control myself
yorp is just on my screen oh i'm ready orp norpin yeah he's
just yorping all right here you go i believe in us we're so
ready no we got this we're so ready it's okay all right
where am i okay here i am what should we go oh we have to go
grab the candy the candy let's go let's go beat him up
trevor beat him up brie i got a taser okay oh they're going
for the big one oh my god i'm trying to pull get the little
ones somebody beat up the big ones while i grab the little
ones i'm grabbing it wait where's i'm i'm punching them okay
where's the guys I actually don't remember where the, where
the, where is our area?
Oh, there it is.
We're red.
Take the candy.
Okay.
I'm grabbing the mini candies.
Don't worry, guys.
I got it.
No.
It's okay.
Oh, we got the big one.
I got the big one.
Nice.
Am I?
Oh, I can't pull it.
I can't pull it.
Help!
I got it!
I need somebody help him!
He's fucking punching me!
I need somebody help him pull it!
I got it!
Big?
I've been punching the shit out of them over here.
Just keep getting the big one and we win.
Okay, I had trouble fucking...
Okay, I need somebody help.
I need help!
Yes!
How do I get this?
You have to go the long way.
You can't do it from there!
Up the ramp!
Guys, help me!
Liam's trying to beat me up!
Liam's got me!
I'm grabbing a small one.
You guys go do your thing.
Grab me a small one too.
Yeah, you guys go do your thing.
Guys, don't tip me!
Don't tip me!
You guys are like...
heading over oh you got the pan oh no they're getting the
big one we need to stop over to be the big one okay I
somebody fell in there guys we need help they're about to
get the big one if you could just keep getting the small
ones it's fine we got him we got him trapped in the hoarder
no don't please i'm just a little dog i'm going to small
ones no go leave run run ditto he's on me i can't okay i
can't i can't i'm just going i got it oh i'm just going i'm
just going oh you stole the big one nice nice yeah yeah yeah
okay nice i'm getting crushed i got three of them down Here
you can steal it.
It's okay.
You know, just keep just keep grabbing.
He's too busy on me.
I got him I got him sun.
All right, good.
It's okay.
Let's go put this on here.
Okay, I'm coming.
I'm coming.
It's so hard to get delivered.
It's so hard.
I get the big one.
Oh my God.
We win.
Wait, yeah.
Guys, I use the cool down.
I used to cool down.
I used to cool down for a small one.
I didn't realize.
A trick!
I can't do well with a pedigree!
One day!
Yippee!
Excellent!
We did it!
A line of my resume by us!
Okay, sure for it, but like, how much did Priya actually
help?
Like, I got a post on it.
clutched out by stealing they clutched out stealing it while
i was just fucking perma knocking three of them on the
ground guys he's yay wait is it do we do it again i don't
know i don't i thought it was only one like best of three
best of three is it again do we have to go through it and
get i get no it's game two is buzz ball What the hell?
Oh, I know Buzzball.
What is Buzzball?
Do we do it?
That's the one where...
I don't know.
Let's just play until something happens.
Yeah, let's just play.
Yeah, they're going for it.
They're going for it.
Oh!
I'm going...
I'm dragging it!
No!
I'm going for the little ones.
Fuck this.
You guys can deal with that.
I know my place.
You got to punch him.
Nice.
You got him.
We won the game.
Yay!
Okay, I'm pretty sure Buzzball is the one where there's a
ball and you have to throw it in the goal and if you hold it
too long, it explodes.
Oh, okay.
Oh, yeah.
It's like soccer.
Okay, I get it.
Yay!
I got a cow!
I got the avatar.
I'm glad we're unlocking characters that we can get for
playing the game once.
It's okay.
I believe in...
You know what?
After that first game, you know what?
I believe in us.
I didn't believe in us before we started, but now I believe
in us.
It's hot.
Oh, I love this one.
If you get into that little thing at the end and you just
press right click, it usually gets thrown in.
Okay.
Boom.
I'm using controllers.
So what's right click on the controller?
I don't know.
I use keyboard and mouse so good luck.
Whatever you throw is, if two people if two people hold on
to the ball it explodes oh okay so we shouldn't hold okay
well you can sometimes it's clutch oh wait you got it you
got it you got it right click it yeah easy to go over your
fucking life you just locked up and just fucking what what
the hell just happened i did it so that's the throw button
That's easy, guys.
Okay, I'll keep them.
No!
Oh, guys!
Enough one.
Okay.
All right, go, go, go!
Okay, I know too!
You got it!
You're going!
Go, go, go!
Oh!
We got big!
No!
Someone punched me out.
It wasn't me, I swear.
I know.
It was an enemy.
Oh!
The bats got it!
No!
Oh!
I got my rocked out.
No!
Punch it, boom!
Get it out!
Just hold on to it.
It's going to go up.
Oh, no!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Oh, no, it's not fine!
It's not fine!
It was in the end.
Not fine.
We got the bad RNG.
I was hoping it would go to their side.
Here we go.
This time we got it.
I believe in us, team.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
That's not...
Nice throw.
Nice, nice, nice.
Come on, go pussy slayer, go!
No, pussy slayer!
I got knocked out.
Oh!
I got knocked out too!
They exploded!
No!
I got knocked out!
Splinter!
Okay, guys, now I don't have confidence anymore.
Hey, we're only down one.
It's like best of four.
last time okay i'll just run and grab it it's six it's six
i'm trying to grab him oh i grabbed him instead you got it
you got it wait what i didn't oh my god it will let me okay
it's okay i'm just running again i'm just running no no
please please have mercy no yes he knocked me up before i
could get there i got knocked out right winnable oh no i got
knocked out Knife down again It's up to you, boys and boys
Oh nice, I came, I kicked him Okay, okay, okay Nice pass Oh,
I knocked him out Get it, get it Throw it in Yay Yay Yay Now
we're tied
We did, we're doing it Guys, we're doing it winnable it is
oh my god it is winnable winnable who would have thought I
got knocked out okay oh it's fine it's fine over here okay I
got you're holding on to me I'm so sorry okay oh nice throw
nice yeah but he's heading over that's goal oh no he pushed
away it's not near our goal anymore i'll wait for you i'll
wait for the throw i'll wait for the throw oh god oh god
wait no he got it again oh big knockout big knockout big
knockout only three more to go oh my god it's gone winnable
yeah Is it?
We can see this.
Pussy Slayer goal!
Got it.
Oh, nice.
Oh, you're juke- Oh!
Oh!
Let's go!
I don't mean practice.
Look at us!
Just run it!
Just do that every single time.
Just run it down mid every single time.
Just run it down!
I knew Tyler Wanderer was right in some ways.
My philosophy, run it down.
Okay, never mind, I'm out.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's fine, he fucked up.
He fucked up.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Oh, no.
Oh no!
No!
He didn't fuck up!
You liar!
It's okay.
This will make the comeback better.
It's fine.
Instead of punching him, I just need to grab him.
Because the punch was missing.
Yeah, that's not good.
I just, I grabbed someone and I dragged him away.
run it down mid run it down mid and then i'll do this let's
go no i'm out i'm out no i'm out you got me i'm out forever
i miss i'm waiting i'm waiting i'm waiting for you nice nice
nice nice
Oh my god, is this the next messy right there?
Those moves.
All right, this is the last one.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I got this.
I couldn't think you aimed it for me.
Oh, God.
Oh, no.
I'm waiting for you guys.
I'm not there.
Fuck out.
Oh, oh, he she needs help.
Do you need help?
Oh, I got it.
Oh, they're fucking they're harassing me.
We won.
Oh, my God, three people can't stop me.
That was four people.
Oh, shit.
Who needs some scrim?
We're just naturally talented.
gonna win oh shit i'm out i can't even oh wait no let me get
the photo i'm a winner i'm a winner
yay is that automatically win for us we don't have to play a
third round right we won we won yeah oh my god what a speed
run speed run all right the round two is luggage chaos beast
soccer and winter is coming what's luggage chaos luggage
chaos is the same thing as the candy one only have to put
the luggage on conveyor belts and then they slowly go into a
separate area that luggage like you can't drag the luggage
into that area you have to like parkour into it and then you
grab the luggage off the conveyor belts okay and then you
put it in like the candy and you just dump it down with the
lever oh okay so it's just the lever stuff again okay so
yeah it's just like slightly confusing like you can't just
walk it to the the dumping place you have to on the conveyor
belt and then it goes through like a little machine and then
you grab it after i see i see okay so like so you it's the
same thing you two are the punching people then did it and i
will just put luggage on the conveyor belt sweet we're doing
it i can't believe i'm actually contributing this time
oh my god this is so different from my last twitch rivals
Did you not do well?
I was not contributing.
And I know what I was doing.
I still don't know what I'm doing, but, like, we're winning,
so that's all that matters.
Constantly say that you do, it's fine.
Is this Connor, as in Connor?
His dance.
Yeah, Connor.
Oh, my God.
Yes, suck it.
I'm going to beat you in the Tech and Get Me Tournament 2.
Unless he's on my team.
Still do it.
Still win.
Suck it.
You're gonna lose to me a Tekken 8 as well.
What is this conversation that you're having?
What?
They were asking about their favorite swear words.
Chib asked me about my favorite swear word.
Oh, okay.
Oh, whoa.
What was it, bitch?
I saw it was bitch, right?
Your name is inappropriate.
I slayed cats.
Yeah, it's a game about slaying animals.
It's just our team.
You're larping.
He likes a lorp.
Oh my god, he loves a lorp, too.
I play Destiny 2.
How do you chat?
Oh, you enter.
Just press enter.
I mean, no, I don't.
I played Destiny 2.
I don't.
If the streams are deleted, doesn't mean it never existed.
Like...
Did you stream it on Tuesdays?
I'm pretty sure that's a special day.
Oh, yeah, that's a special Tuesday.
Every Tuesday.
Sunday is the only sacred day.
Why is Sunday a sacred day?
Because I don't play Overwatch.
That's Variety Day.
When you're... when you're... Wait, I thought Tuesday's a
Variety Day.
And what the fuck is Tuesday?
No, that's Wednesday.
Wednesday and Sunday.
Wednesday is Sunday.
Wait, then what's Tuesday?
We don't talk about it.
What's Tuesday?
If Tuesday... if... If... Then is it Overwatch?
So you stream Overwatch with your V-Tuber?
No.
Then what the fuck is Tuesday?
Do you say whatever I wanted to be?
It's whatever I wanted to be.
Yeah.
Valid, valid, valid.
I'm valid.
You're valid.
That's right.
You are.
Okay, apparently we finished it so fast that we have to wait
for the other games to be done.
We're just that good.
We're that bad.
Okay, until we face- We're so good at this game.
Until we face the Apex team that's in this.
The Apex.
Wait, which team is that?
I don't know.
That is team.
It's drops.
It's team.
It's rogue's team team six.
That's the apex team because no, I think we could go against
them I mean, these are basically like training rounds, you
know?
Yeah, but it's gonna just determine our seeding.
Oh Yeah So we're it's like the seeded matches.
Oh My god seeds.
Wow.
Oh my god Did are you awake did oh?
Yeah, right?
He's not dead inside It was just chilling It was vibing at 4
in the morning I haven't I haven't um slept yet.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I was like the main story.
Oh shit I was like they had a concert and stuff too.
Oh, yes.
Yes.
Yes It took me like 10 hours to finish the main story 10
hours yeah yesterday yes 10 hours wait how long did how long
you been playing hong kai um today yesterday do you start
yesterday oh no um maybe what one month one month ago it
took like one month of like i i first um i started um
painting this game on the first day and i stopped playing it
and i just oh my god oh my god how much money did you spend
Um...
You don't count it.
It doesn't matter how much you spend the money on this game.
It doesn't matter!
Yeah.
If it doesn't matter, then you would tell me how much you
spend, right?
It does matter if you have fun or not.
Yeah, so...
So if it doesn't matter how much you spend, then you should
be open to telling me how much you spend.
I can't remember.
You can't remember!
I can't remember No, I agree I think you should actually To
celebrate finishing it I think you should spend even more
money on it I think you should celebrate Just do more How
many characters do you have On Honkai It's not that much
Because I just came back Or maybe
Let me shake Let me let me open up Hongkai real quick.
Let me shake.
Wait, how many characters is Hongkai even have?
I have 37 characters.
Wait, out of how many?
Are you missing any character?
Out of 37.
Yeah, yeah.
Out of 37?
Wait, how do you know sure for it?
I don't know anything about Hongkai Star Real.
Wait, do you even gotcha?
a lot of people i only play gotcha games with pvp yeah like
what well the last one i played was afk arena i think afk
arena isn't that like a fucking youtube ad sponsor game yeah
it was yeah i see it everywhere i'll see it all on tick tock
i played that shit like seven years ago wait that is that
old it's existed for that long it's 2018 holy yes sir i
haven't played a gotcha The last gotcha game I played was
like Genshin because I was like hella bored.
How do you think about Genshin?
Did you like it or did you stop because it was boring?
They made gone you so they got that going for me.
Yeah, that got gone you.
Listen, gotcha games.
I only play gotcha games for PvP because like the whole
point of gotcha games is supposed to be like buying Gucci
wallets but for like weebs.
They're supposed to be flexing other PvP roster.
I'm surprised you haven't tried out Nikkei.
Why the fuck would I play Nikkei?
If I wanted to look at anime girl ass, I would look at
something else.
Like what?
Like what then?
Yeah?
Yeah.
What do you say?
I think that's self-explanatory.
Wait, what do you say?
You know what that is?
What do you say?
It's a pentai.
I can't play no gotcha game for that.
That's not cool.
All right, chat.
Rate his taste.
Is it...
Wait, this is a few of a chat.
Like, do you have any recommendations?
Now, there's some good ones, but I'm not going to say them
out loud.
That's TOS.
You actually getting bad, saying it?
Pushing Slayer isn't TOS.
Yeah, but you say it out loud on Twitch instead of writing
it down, is it really bannable?
Well, pay their gotcha games for that.
That's similar.
Why would I pay for it when it's free on the internet?
That's true.
It's for the experience.
Hell no.
I want it to be a competition, okay?
you can make it competitive it's like how are you gonna make
that competitive
chat can try no way your chat can find a way not my chat my
chat is say so christian friendly oh okay is full of
intellectuals yeah are you dying you okay i'm sorry after
hearing you say your chat's filled with intellectuals i
couldn't take you seriously anymore what the hell is that
supposed to mean
wait there there we have to ignore the bracket a mistake was
made reporting a match oh wait which was oh wait what's
going on i don't even know what the bracket is whose bracket
is it
i mean they can't really make a mistake with ours because we
just did yeah like ours was like Yeah.
So clear cut.
Yeah.
You said your chat is like, say, isn't that the whole thing
like not, like what, what is say, like not lewd?
Yeah.
Hey, listen, anyone that says like say so, they're like,
it's like the Christianity of V-tubing.
They're like whole closeted freaks.
Whoa!
What is that supposed to be?
It's like Christian girls, you know, they're like freaks.
Whoa!
whoa they promised their bodies to god yeah and then they
threw that away once they got a taste of the forbidden fruit
feels like you're speaking from experience experience oh my
god when is our fucking when is our next bracket gonna start
we did too good that we We won too quickly.
We're just too good.
Next time I'll try to play worse.
No, no, no, we got to be faster next time.
I get it.
Next time.
Next time we got to be even faster.
We watched you walk into their goal in the first five.
I don't think we can be faster.
Look, they just couldn't register.
They couldn't register what I did there.
Oh, I like the fact that we have Pussy Slayer on the team so
that...
As we do better and better, we just have to constantly pay
attention to the first Pussy Slayer as they talk about it.
That, I thrive on that.
I got AFK kicked from the lobby.
So I was on the tab personally.
I almost got AFK kicked as well.
I'm going to use this time to runescape, actually.
You got a runescape?
Wait, what are you grinding for?
I'm getting my warp scepter right now so then I can clear
barrows more efficiently.
Wait, wait, what's...
go is that well warp scepter is for magic and then barrows
is for barrows gear barrows yes and then so you're trying to
get better gear right now yeah i'm getting mid gear for my
iron man oh you're iron manning oh that makes sense oh my
god he's multitasking just like a true overwatch player
while waiting q yeah he's maxing maxing
I Forgot about how long it takes in between matches Yeah,
that's why you have to start saying like start making jokes
or something.
Oh, yeah help you Yeah, just call right now Help entertain
your chat re-entertain my chat for me my my chat's like
sludge Yeah, be funny for my chat Brie this is your purpose
now what what what did the what was the pirate's favorite
letter what oh no it's the it's the C's stupid he's ah you
just call me stupid what the if you think you're so smart
what's 25 plus 25 72 that's not that What?
It's not 72.
I said so confidently.
Why is it 72?
I don't know.
Where did the 72 come from?
Everything's falling apart.
Everything.
Oh no.
Our momentum is gone.
We lost our momentum.
Nar.
No.
We were kicked out.
That means they're making the room, right?
No.
You got AFK.
kick kick maybe no no they removed us yeah they moved us
we're fighting we're fighting kendomers now what dude yeah
finally get off runescape oh yippee no get off runescape
right now i'm getting to my tortoises and then i'll get off
i'm almost there let's see
the twitch rivals and then the twitch rivals it's not
showing up it showed up for me I just copied and pasted
that's actually good I don't know why I'm typing them
manually you know okay I wonder if they won their last one
guys did the Kendall Murti win their last round stream snipe
for me right now but like but not like unethically
unethically ethically stream sniped just to tell me if they
won their last game they did wait they did they're gamers
they won their last match so they might be gamers where the
fuck is pussy slay oh yeah he's still walking over yeah the
last man there yeah stream sniped respectfully, guys.
Candle Mers.
They're here to get you guys win your last match.
Win your last match.
Oh, they did.
They did?
I know.
I just wanted them to respond.
I know they did, so I want to see if they lied to me.
Oh, no.
I asked them immediately.
Okay.
We're bad.
It's here.
We're making...
We're going to make them think that we're really bad so they
go easy on us.
That's a good idea.
Yeah, yeah.
We got two owed.
Two owed us.
Okay, we got it.
We have to make them underestimate us.
we see it was a huge
it's okay we can do this guys we can do this what the fuck
is this that's the I haven't played this one before on the
conveyor belt in the middle and then it goes under those
little like a little like platform yeah you guys have to
beat them up the candy thing yeah yeah so you and you are
gonna beat them up as usual i'm just gonna beat the out of
them yeah and they can go uh and take things from the
conveyor belt in like both the hub area and then our
separate little area where we score points so like oh we
gotta just keep them keep it on okay okay so we'll figure
this out right we're gonna we're gonna figure this out yeah
i believe in you guys i'm just gonna punch it thank you that
works honestly all right here we go wait there's a Yeah,
it's worth a lot.
Yeah, somebody grab the gold.
It's in the midst.
Oh!
No, he got it!
Wait, he just ran into the thing.
I'm going into their spawn.
Wait, what color are we?
Are we red?
Okay, I'm going to red.
I'm going to red.
I'm trying to pull.
Guys, they're all pulling me.
I can't even bring the luggage over.
They're pulling me.
I'm out.
Guys, they're really good.
The gold briefcase is stuck.
I'm stuck under it.
Wait, no, we lost man down!
I can't roll!
How do I get over?
Guys, how do I...
Wait, it's actually...
How do I get over this?
Oh, thank you!
Guys, how do I...
How do we get over?
Guys, I don't...
You can't get over with you have a...
If you have a suitcase in your hand.
Oh, wait, then...
You have to put it on the conveyor belt.
Guys, I think they're winning.
Yeah, they are.
We were so- No, I'm spawn camping them.
We're so confused about this game mode.
Okay.
I need help.
They're harassing me.
They're picking me up.
I can get off.
This isn't going well.
Wait, we have too many people on their side.
You're taking it away from them!
You're taking it away from the goal!
Wait, I am.
Put it here and then put it under there.
Oh!
Where are you?
I figured it out.
It's fine.
We can catch up, surely.
I don't know.
We can catch up.
It's fine.
They're harassing me right now.
I'm here.
They're putting a lot in my end.
I figured out how to do this, but these guys are actually...
Okay, okay.
If you just hold it.
Yeah.
I can't.
Oh no!
I'm dead.
They trained!
They have a goal!
They actually know what to do.
No, you grabbed me!
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I grabbed a key still.
Okay.
Okay, I'm pulling.
Go to the lever, go to the lever, it's fine.
I'm just doing it.
God,
oh, please, we're so new.
I said feel nicer to us, why are they being nice?
This isn't going well.
Oh, sorry, sorry.
That was a bad hit.
Oh my God, this is so hard.
Oh, they're so good, I'm getting one man harassed.
They took my hat.
Guys, this might be This might be above our pay grade This
might be This might be a team That might win this Take it, I
fucked them up Okay, okay I got them?
Okay I dropped it, we're good Oh shit What?
I knocked me out!
Wait, there's a taser gun on my end Oh no!
There's a taser gun on my end guys This might be a GG go
next.
Yeah, this is like...
Okay, no, no, we gotta get a strat, dad.
It's fine.
This is probably...
I don't think this is our map.
This is definitely not our game.
Okay, the next one?
There's...
Guys, we definitely know we're bad now.
It's okay.
The next one is the soccer game.
Oh, shit.
We can do that.
Okay, I'll beat...
So, I'll beat up the goalie.
That's my job.
Okay.
I'll just beat up the goalie.
the bully and you guys do the other stuff that's just not
our mode yeah guys this is not the the apex pro team that
scrimmed every day well these guys have scrimmed they know
what they're doing they have plans yeah maybe they were
maybe the apex team was scrimming this team honestly round
two fight where are we playing a round two no i think we're
just i think we're just waiting yeah the owner has only the
instructions were definitely on we can win this game oh
they're minecraft that makes so much more sense oh minecraft
they're well coordinated minecraft players are the god
gamers of games they're just there oh my gosh i remember
when i did twitch rivals in fortnite and a minecraft player
won like top five or something oh my god yeah in the
fortnite okay this one i think we have to headbutt more uh i
don't know middle mouse button okay instructions unclear
That's okay.
We can lose like one round one one matchup.
It's no we can't lose Otherwise, it'll seem like we're
cheating.
We just did the you know It'll make the story better.
That's true.
Oh, we're already going.
Oh, this is not good.
Oh, we went two of them are knocked out though two of them
already knocked out I'm going over I'm going over to beat up
the the goalie Oh, no, I got it out.
It's fine.
It's okay.
I'm beating up the goalie and I are distracted for our team
distracting the goalie.
We can't hit each other.
I got ball in midfield.
Okay, okay.
I got the goalie out.
The goalie's out.
The goalie's back in.
We're trying to get the ball in mid.
I got knocked out.
Guys, I'm distracting the goalie.
That's good.
That's this goalie is so out now.
We're doing our part.
I'm doing my part.
Get out.
Oh no!
It hit the top left!
The goalie was good!
Listen, this ball is hard to control sometimes.
oh my god that was a good hit too i'm really bad at rocket
league this is not yeah this is literally a 3v3 to be fit
this is a 3v3 the goalie and i we're not believing it out
right now get out golly we're fine we're fine we're fine
we're fine oh it's okay the goalie and having we're having
our own slam I don't have enough Sam I didn't have enough
Sam I'm out I'm dead
hey this ball it's hard to control they're like all rolling
and stuff to go faster yeah i keep forgetting oh god oh i'm
out i'm a why ball i'm out but don't worry i'm gonna get
that goalie out too oh god that's right you thought you
could have it chill that's right how the do you roll in this
game i don't know what it is for controller oh i figured it
out oh he knocked me out but that's okay he thought he He
can have it good.
That's fucking right.
Get distracted by me.
No!
What the?
What?
That was like this.
I just snagged him.
I won my game.
Guys, I think if they score the next one it's over.
What's going on?
Holy shit!
What the fuck am I watching you?
We're joking.
Maybe we need another one.
Maybe we need another player.
There you go.
I did it.
So he spent the entire game just fighting someone in the
quarter and then instantly won.
It's just that easy.
What can I say?
It's actually that fucking easy.
That's fucking right, Rabbit.
You thought it was done with you?
The goalie's distracted again!
The goalie's...
You think I was done with you?
Oh my god.
I'm dead.
I'm coming back.
Don't worry.
I'm the striker.
The little bear guy here or the corgi.
He's the one that sets up the combo.
Oh shit.
That's fine.
It's fine.
Oh shit.
Guys, I don't know.
I'm gonna fucking beat up this guy though.
Okay.
Oh no.
No!
You're so good.
I'm rolling as well.
I'm doing their strat Okay, I'm waiting for you guys No,
okay Oh, no.
Oh, no, I'm waiting.
I'm waiting for the fucking Oh, no Thank you.
No Oh my god.
That's so close Okay Oh, I hit it down.
I hit it down mid.
Okay, I'm putting over here.
I lost my hat.
No, no, I lost my hat No, my hat's blocking me My hat
actually blocked me.
The one time.
Oh, nice one.
The one time I didn't distract the goalie.
It's over here.
It's okay.
The one time I knew I should never left my post.
You thought you could get away from me.
Okay, she did got away from me.
Swicking right.
Oh!
The goalie's gone.
The goalie's gone!
Quick!
Okay.
Yeah, well, we need to get the bro over there.
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
I feel like I have to play defense.
I'm scared.
I didn't want you guys to go there while I distract the
goalie.
The problem is I need to play defense.
I can't play Dws offense at the same time.
That's what midfield is.
That's what midfield is D in offense.
That's the name for midfield.
go full offense then oh wait all right i'm going on the
offense all right okay okay all right what the it's back oh
my god oh my god okay all right you're not sure you go
offense i'll do meet mid okay i can't punch oh my god oh my
god jumping jumping and kicking into it is very good
Wait, I thought you were fucking offense.
What happened?
I'm just trying to do what I think will be the best right
now.
Look at that.
Look at that edge.
Yeah, but there's no offense.
There's no offense.
I'm scared.
If I'm not over there, the ball's going to go into the goal.
Oh, big pass.
There you go.
Go pass.
Go offense.
This is your job.
Yeah, well, unfortunately, I pass it mid.
Oh my god.
You're passing, okay.
I'm going it, I'm going up.
You know how soccer works and it's not passing.
I thought you were offense.
Fucking offense.
I can't solo Ronaldo this.
I thought you were messy.
What happened?
I saw.
Let's go.
Watch our fire.
What is this?
I have three on me.
we have a minute i'm trying i got it i got it
all i'm saying is i would have scored nice block bullshit
we definitely lost i did score though i gave us our one
point score i set up that score i jumped kicked i jumped
kicked into it at the start
it's just so sad it just wasn't for us this was not around
we were against minecraft if this was banjo ball if this was
banjo ball they would have been on what the what the is
banjo ball it's a warcraft 3 custom game you should say up a
warcraft three twitch rivals and then invite them back i've
been saying that i've been saying that wait why can't you do
it i'm not a set up guy you're not a set up guy no you
basically i'm like a side character main character oh okay
wait but like twitch rivals is like it's like really easy
though to set up because like twitch does most of the work
nah then i would have to like message someone that's out of
my pay grade they come to you i'd rather play runescape
has there ever been a runescape choice which rivals uh
they've had like dead man modes and what's dead man mode i
don't it's like basically where you play runescape normally
but you have insane xp rates and if you die once you're out
of the tournament oh like a giant battle royale Roomscape
map.
Wait, were you part of it or...
Hell no.
I know, it seems...
Why do I thought you love Roomscape?
I'm not that autistic.
But you are on the spectrum though, because I remember you
took the test.
You took...
Hell no.
Yes, you did.
You took the test!
Listen, every time I've gone to a psychologist, they've said
I'm normal.
I don't want to tell you.
But you took the test!
It's okay.
Are you saying that an internet test is better?
It was a really good internet test though.
It was like a couple of pages like.
They were trying to make me take the test and I was like,
I'm scared of knowing what I am.
It said I might be.
Oh.
Wait, do you remember the number?
Uh, there's a different, in one Discord I'm in, we make sure
everyone takes the test and then we put the number beside
their name of the test.
That's really funny.
What's the number?
I was a 28, but if I answer the question, like I'm able to
imagine things, I was a six.
Who does that mean?
I can't imagine things.
I was a, oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, empathy, yes, yeah.
Yeah.
I was a 169.
I think different tests.
I'm thinking went that high.
Oh, okay.
is that wait wait how higher is more it's more oh more
flavor more flavor yeah just a more i guess like a more more
delicious type yeah that's yeah autism is tasty yummy
apparently there's one more game they have to wait to
finish.
And then...
That we weren't the slowest.
That was like the world's longest match.
That was the longest soccer match ever though.
That wasn't that long.
Actually, to be fair, we did lose really quickly and then
the last one was just long.
Okay, the luggage one was, yeah.
That was a disaster.
The luggage one was, yeah, that was a, I accidentally like
took some of our briefcases to the end.
Oh my god.
I was confused.
I was The instructions were so unclear You'll get it next
time That's okay If they put that in that If they put
another round of that in there It'll be easy We'll know what
we do We have a system We'll be We're gonna be so ready for
the next round I'm always ready What is the third Third game
The third round is team score into the game.
What's into the game?
Oh, is that the arcade?
No, we're doing winter is coming.
No, that's the, that's game.
That's round two.
Oh.
Are we still on round?
Oh, wait, no.
We're on round three.
Yeah, yeah.
We lost two.
All right.
Into the game.
Yeah, so.
Am I out of Google it?
Can I Google that?
That's the, that's the arcade one.
Yeah, the arcade.
Ooh.
Um.
Oh my god.
So we need someone that we need someone that's dedicated and
going into the game.
I can do that.
We can also like I found out that if you like take their
arcade machine, you can take you can like go to the bombs
yourself and make them lose score.
Oh yeah, but I feel like that's a waste because then you're
just gonna get punched out.
That's true.
Or do you still get the shield when you go into there?
Yeah, you get the shield though.
So like it's worth the risk to make them lose points.
And you're wasting time.
Yeah.
i feel like if you knock them out you go to oh team joki
feel free to leave the lobby they want us to leave okay why
do we have to leave okay i guess we lost this is they're the
losers we have every winner there is a loser i thought we
were gonna win um
oh my gosh you know like when they did the year of luigi
like nintendo ended up losing so much money for that so they
never give luigi anything ever again really yeah it was like
their worst financial year ever because that's the damn
problem with these corpos they just look at the finances and
not to live for other characters their goddamn shareholders
and stockholders got them by the britches i'm telling you
it's not about the money luigi didn't deserve this i got my
work set
oh yeah high-five rush that's so sad when i the the company
the company closed i'll remember you always that's so sad do
i charge this thing charge what my warp scepter that i got
yeah i'm xp maxing right now wait that's true i should go do
my dailies wait not on runescape but yeah did are you doing
your dailies did you Do you do your Han Kai, Han Kai
dailies?
Yeah.
Did you do your...
I'm doing it right now.
You're doing it right now.
See?
We're all XP maxing right now.
Am I the only one just relaxing, just chilling?
Hey, I have the ability to multitask, so...
That's a lie.
Multitasking is a real.
I'm literally doing it right now.
I'm talking, I'm streaming, I'm runescaping.
Yeah, but then you're like...
using less of your Twitter I'm all tabbing yeah but then
you're putting like 20% of effort on each on each of it so
you're not putting 100% effort yeah but runescape is very
AFKable yeah but then you're doing all these other stuff too
at once so you're splitting your mind you're splitting your
mind so it's not like actual min maxing your min your min
mining no i'm max minning you're minning okay wait oh yeah
the lobby's up by the way did this team win their last game
did joe bartolosi won their last game chat
wait joe is the only that's the tick tock that's the tick
tocker he's a tick tocker who's he's a tick tocker Wait,
what does he tick tocks?
What tick tock does he do?
He screams.
Wait, how many followers does he have?
A lot.
Joe.
Yeah, I think a lot.
Bart.
Is he an actual real guy?
Oh my god, he is a real guy.
Wait, wait.
What does that mean?
Holy shit, he has 24 million followers?
What the fuck does he do?
Oh my god, what is tick tocks like?
screams yeah that's it that's good to know all right i'm
gonna watch this okay i'm actually curious what is this tick
tock oh
he's a reactor yeah he screams that's it that's that's how
he reacts wait where's my 24 million followers i scream all
the time one two zero no we lost we lost We are very bad.
Shhh.
Lucky.
Watch me.
Oh, I did.
I did invite you.
Okay, I'll do my union.
Oh, good.
Good point.
Sorry to break it to you, Bucco.
Bro, he's a party animal streamer.
That is...
I'm sorry.
What?
What is a party down here?
You have to do that.
He tells me to win.
If you get kicked off.
Wait, wait, what?
What do you mean?
Like
All right We're ready All right into that game Okay I'll
work on doing Wait who's defending I'm just gonna beat the
shit out of them Okay but are you defending beating the shit
out of them Or offense beating the shit out of them Offense
Offense okay I'll go with short for it And then Breon did
it'll go defense Okay I'll focus on Arcade All right we got
this Arcade?
League of Legends?
Oh my god Season 3 The misery everybody wants to be my
enemy.
Wow Are we ready?
Cat chest.
Weddy.
I don't know if I wrote ready yet Okay, apparently they lost
their last game too.
So like whoever loses this one is the biggest loser Yeah,
guys I don't know if I can handle losing again What will
happen if you lose sure for what will you do night sky gets
angry even the devil shutters
guys we don't want your fort to lose again we don't know
like we don't know what he's gonna be like after there's
still there's still two teams below you yes because we're
one to one wait that means there's a team that lost every
game that's not that's still because we had our one already
maybe it was the people that we went against the first time
and maybe we they were just not good at the game and we got
false help look look this team is this team is a bunch of
tick tockers actually i don't know but like yeah i only know
one tick we're just a bunch of vtubers so like i'm not i'm
normal sure you are oh this one is so hard yeah yeah your
your Okay.
All right, here we go.
We got this.
All right, it's fine.
I will beat everyone up.
Wait, what if there's an actual Minecraft player on Joe's
team?
Oh no.
It's over.
They have a Minecraft.
It's over here.
Minecraft's to be one.
No.
Okay.
I'm fucking going here.
I'm going in.
We're blue.
now you fucking punched me I thought you were going in the
machine wait don't I thought you were going in ours who's
going in ours no I'm doing doing office with you oh okay I'm
picking the arcade when I do we need we need people at our
machines all right I'm getting in I'm getting in All right,
you get involved.
You get involved.
Wait, we need to stop them though.
Oh God.
Wait, who's getting in ours?
I don't know, but I'm okay.
I think that was Dokey.
No, wait.
No, I said I'm doing offense.
I'm doing offense and I'm doing theirs.
That's what I'm making.
I'm punching and punching.
You got it.
Yes.
No.
Okay, I'm gonna need you to.
Oh wait.
Okay.
Okay, I got- Yeah, they did.
They did.
Grab it so I can get onto the bomb
Why would it grab the fucking stick?
Okay, you go, you go, you go.
I'm trying to.
I'll try to grab.
I'll punch them.
You go, you go.
Okay, okay.
Go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go.
They got me off.
Okay.
Give me.
I'm gone.
I'm on it.
I'm passed out.
Okay, we're all passed out.
Wait, you guys, you guys haven't grabbed anything.
We're trying.
Okay.
No.
They got in.
Okay.
No.
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry.
That was my bad.
Oh, God.
You got it.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
No.
I'm out.
Oh, my God.
He.
They're so good.
These are mines out there.
I got some points.
I'm trying to grab me the machine on the stick.
Oh, my God.
When you're on it, they can knock you out.
I noticed that you don't have a shield when you're on it.
Guys, I think it's over.
when you're on the enemies.
That's okay.
I think it's over.
No, we got it.
We got it over.
I think it's over, guys.
Keep fighting!
I think it's over.
I'm trying.
I knocked them out.
Grab the stick.
I'm trying.
I'm going to knock that too.
No, we got it.
We got it.
We're fine.
Okay.
I'm trying to knock them out.
Tripp, are you knocking them out?
Of course I am.
I got the bomb.
I splashed it with the bomb.
My point.
Oh, they got it!
Sheebar.
Oh,
it's okay.
We have the second round.
Guys, we have the second round.
Look, they have a Minecrafty.
What's the second round?
The second round is...
It's Beast Hockey.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Okay, the Hockey.
That has ice.
Okay, I'm really...
Lemonade, my neck was dripping.
All I'm gonna do is I'm gonna beat up the goalie.
That's all I'm gonna do.
I'm just here to beat up the goalie.
Oh my god.
That's supposed to be my.
That's supposed to be my strat.
Wait, no you don't.
You're the one to score.
Well, usually when I play these, I only try and grief the
enemy team.
Okay, okay.
But like, are you good at scoring, though?
I don't know.
Wait, I'm going to beat up the goalie.
goalie and then i'm gonna i'm gonna steal a shield my i'll
try my best i'm gonna steal this shield after wait that's
dank dank it's okay joki but you're Canadian look I have
very limited knowledge on hockey other than other than I
played a knucks team I played a lot of hockey when I was
younger You should be the scorer.
I say you're...
Yeah.
I played right side defense when I played hockey.
Oh yeah, today you're gonna be offense today.
I'm offensive.
Okay, don't worry, I'm going in.
I'm going in to see this.
Wait, wait.
I got it out.
I'm distracted the goalie.
Sure, for this is like this is your time.
I stole it.
Sure for.
Sure for what happened.
What the fuck you want from me?
I literally saved us.
And then I got knocked out.
Like, what am I supposed to do here?
All I'm saying is you had the Canadian buff.
Listen, it's not just me.
Remember, 80%.
Who's our goalie?
It's not me.
I'm out.
I'm fucking stealing your shield.
Oh, no!
We have no goalie!
Oh, my offense, oh, my goalie!
It's not me.
There's no one there!
The enemy team picked up our shield that they're supposed to
use!
I said I was- I wasn't Goldie.
Whoa!
Get it in.
I'm knocked out!
I'm out.
I'm out cold.
I'm fucking dead.
Nice.
Winnable.
Nippy!
What's going on here?
Oh, come on!
You idiot!
See, you say I'm offense, but we got two on the offensive
side, so I have to play defense.
Wait, we can have two off offense.
But then we have no defense.
Oh, wait, what about the other girls?
What are you trying to say about the other girls?
All I'm saying is I'm the flex right now.
Okay, look, I'm getting rid of the goalie right now.
I'm getting rid of the goli the goli got rid of me though I
punished them Okay, I'll try and do just punching them all
out.
They stole our shield.
They stole our shield I got the shield.
I'm coming back for you guys.
Oh I got the shield for you too right
He king
No!
Damn!
I hit you.
Oh, yeah.
It's okay.
I'm getting my wood.
Oh my god, bro, this guy is a Minecraft right there.
Oh!
What's going on?
They grabbed our shield.
They grabbed your shield?
I got it.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Grab the shield back.
Nice, nice.
It's okay.
Here, do you want me to defend?
You go.
I got the shield!
Oh!
Nice!
They got the shield back.
I knocked that bit out.
Okay, yeah, you can tell this guy's a party animal player.
Ow!
Oh, I died!
Oh, I didn't knock him out!
Nice!
I got the goalie!
And I got the shield!
Woo!
Go!
What is happening to this puff?
Y'all knocked one out.
Oh, fuck.
Oh my god.
Goink.
Nice, okay.
Ugh!
They're sure for it.
Oh, I jumped!
That's a key right!
Yeah!
Guys, this is all looking so good.
No, no, no, no.
This is our comeback.
It's good.
It's our comeback.
It's so winnable.
Guys, we're losers, too.
Okay, okay, I'm coming in to actually help for real Okay,
hey, I'm for real this time For real, for real, I'm actually
you I shall assist Okay I shall use my Canadian debuff
That's it, Jill Bart You've knocked me out too many times Oh
my god Oh my god You're serious now I'm heading over What do
you want me to do I'm literally here You hit you Runago
Runago You hit me twice Runago I set that up for you man I
set it up Yeah and I knocked out two of them motherfuckers
Okay I'm waiting I'm waiting for the pass Okay Oh not that
bad Yes.
Oh, no.
Go close your post.
Oh, shit.
I almost knocked you out.
Oh, nice, nice.
Nice.
It's a party animal.
Guys, I got some bad news.
They only need one more.
Oh, guys, guys.
Surely, surely we can come back.
It's a comeback right here, right?
Surely.
Okay.
They're just getting hard bullied, though.
It's a comeback.
It's so winnable.
It's the comeback of the century.
This is it.
Oh, shit.
Our goalie's down.
Okay.
Oh, I'm down.
Ow.
Oh,
this is just a round robin.
We're not last because we won our one game.
That's automatic.
That's true.
We're not last.
Does that mean we progress or are we out?
So then we have seated after this.
Then it's like single elimination.
I think.
It's single elimination after this.
Which is good.
We purposely lost so we can get easier games.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Adoki, I have some bad news for you.
That's not how cheating works.
If you're lashed, that means you go against, that means you
go against top seed, which means you go against the hardest.
No, that's not how that works.
No way.
That's how that works, actually.
No, no.
Where did you get those rules?
Who told you that?
I was your pro player.
Who told you, you were a pro player but it's- you were a pro
player.
But thing, times have changed.
Times have not changed.
Maybe in the V2 video world.
But this is the Twitch rivals.
This is the Twitch rivals.
It's not V2 exclusive.
Okay, but like why would they put us in the, why would they
put us in a harder queues?
wake up to reality nothing goes right in this accursed world
no but things are supposed to go right things supposed to be
our world crying emoji okay all right how is the seating
where okay second stage single elimination best of three
games first to three points oh it's first to three points oh
okay uh wait but it doesn't even even tell oh i think it's
just is it just beat him up or quote no quarter foul he
knows conveyor trebuchet wind tunnel oh no what's conveyor
okay can oh god wait what is conveyor shrug what is conveyor
what is conveyor guys what is it oh it's a big conveyor yeah
but is it like pvp or last stand is like pvp you have to
dump people off um like you there's a bunch of weapons that
spawn in and then you you pick them up and then you dump
them off this night okay so hopefully this should be good
because it's just beating people up yeah yeah hopefully
that'll be that'll be easy right yeah i love beating people
up yeah see that's good
i'm buying earth runes right now hopefully We got this.
You're min-minning again?
Yeah.
Okay, back to my dailies.
Back to your dailies?
Free entertain us.
I'm playing Neopets!
Entertain us!
I got more poor stuff to do!
People still play Neopets?
Yeah, they like recently...
They recently sold Neopets to some tech guy who is like a
Neopets fan.
Yeah, like, it's actually like doing stuff.
Yeah, they're rebuilding the, uh, they're rebuilding the...
Does it still look like it was made in 2001?
No, it's...
Yes.
Well, okay.
It looks like it was made in, like, 2012.
Huh.
They upgraded it a little bit.
Right.
I know, like, I know they're trying to do, like,
something...
Uh...
I know they're trying to do, like...
some updates to it and adding new game modes.
Yeah, now they're doing a lot.
And like, they're doing events and stuff finally.
And they brought back unconverted pets, which is amazing.
Oh, yeah, I remember that.
I remember that.
Because they send like a fucking newsletter out to everybody
about it.
Yeah.
I'm autistic enough that I cried when they brought back a
unconverted pet.
Yeah, because then you can like, you people were like
selling it for like crazy amount of real money.
It was like hundreds of dollars.
If you could get a Pokemon, or Pokemon and a Neopet with
like a good name.
It was genuinely hundreds of dollars.
It was like, yeah.
And I remember like you can actually buy like real Neopoints
and like real paintbrushes like and stuff with real fucking
money.
Wait, do you actually cry?
Yeah, no, because I'm autistic.
That wasn't a joke.
I was just, you know, you know, I got us fairy sweet hug.
was really happy okay I was living a really good life yeah I
miss Neopets I used to like grind that game as if it was a
fucking job dude same when I was like really young because
like that was my life and all oh yeah when I was young I had
like yeah my did I did Neopet dailies just like how people
today do get do Genshin dailies and Han Kai yeah yeah no I
did that when I was a When I was a child.
Yeah, I stopped when I became an adult.
Sunny Neo or something.
Sunny Neo!
And then they would have like a checklist of like, here's
some stuff you have to do every day.
And then I would click every link every day to make sure I
get my dailies done.
Yeah, Pets was my gotcha.
Yes, but it was free.
The only time I was spending was...
The only thing I was spending was my time.
Time is...
Time is money.
I was not spending actual money.
I didn't get scammed into doing the whole what was it in the
the neopets exclusive shit Doki is just hurting my feelings
right now every single sentence yeah imagine spending money
on me I didn't spend real money on that into the neomall
that's wild imagine spending money I know right imagine
spending money on neomall and neopets premium for the super
wizard just because you wanted to like search up the lowest
prices Yeah, it's not worth your time.
That's crazy.
I don't know what the hell's going on.
So he's hurting my feelings and making fun of my spending
choices.
That's what's happening.
That's sick.
Oh, my God.
I got priorities, okay?
My priorities are very stupid.
Oh, my God.
You know, like when we're fighting Joe's team, a bunch of
his... I don't know if it was happening in your chat, but a
bunch of his chatters came to my chat just to, like, like
cheer for Joe.
Really?
That's funny.
What supportive guys?
And then when we lost, we're like, yeah, Joe's better.
And I'm just like, what's up?
Happy little guys.
Got to tone down that happiness there to their own chat.
Chat hoppers.
Yeah.
Preview.
That's true.
It's not showing up with the map.
What?
What do you mean?
The new game.
It's not showing up.
New game.
Oh, the quarterfinals?
Oh, shit.
The quarterfinals.
Who played against these people?
Zuri Sparks.
No, they're all new people.
Nice.
Alright, if we lose this, we're out.
Just so you guys know.
It is lovely.
Life or death, for real.
It won't feel so good, Mr. Crows.
It's life or death.
Right here.
Wait, it is not showing up.
You're right.
Yeah, it's not.
I thought you were lying.
Right now.
Why would I be lying?
I thought you were lying about this.
Compulsive liar.
I know, because you're about your resume, so...
I'm sorry.
You saw that first round, I carried at least two things to
that.
Did we see that second and third round?
I think that was, you know, I'm just being held back, you
know, I'm not...
Name names right now!
Who is it?
Uh, you know, I don't really want to, but, you know, not to
cause any drama, but, you know, I'm just saying that I'm not
being, like, let, like, you know, show my true, you know,
skill in this game.
All right.
Why is it not showing up?
I want to join.
I want to be part still not created yet oh we okay team
squeaks and team Joe are against each other so if we win
this we might have to go against Joe again Joe mama okay
that's weird I haven't seen it yet all right somebody sent
this guy a friend or friend ID and I will invite you and
then breathe you you give your ID there and then invite us.
Okay.
Copy.
What's going on?
Oh, apparently the room is not showable, so like they have
to invite us individually with the friend ID.
What the?
So we're just gotta wait.
Just gotta wait.
The first one to die is dead weight.
Alright, everyone make sure Doki Doki.
What?
I'm the captain.
I can't beat Deadweight.
I literally...
Captains are usually the Deadweight.
I literally scored.
Captains are usually supposed to just be the charismatic
person to bring people together, not to actually do
anything.
It's like a CEO.
Okay.
But I actually did stuff.
Keep telling yourself that.
Oh, yeah.
The first game.
I scored almost all the goals in the first game.
game the second game i scored the second game i scored the
only goal in the second game that was luck i also kicked it
forward i knocked two people out i knocked two people oh
yeah game three i set up the goal for you i knocked two
people out before you set it up see this is the
self-centered thinking we're talking about here this is team
games but you're only thinking about what yeah but you're
self-centered as well because you were telling people that
you did all that stuff as well 80% of the team blasts which
rivals my story matters
What what is a friend ID um is in your fucking profile in
party hours Are they just waiting for us?
Where are you?
Where is this room?
what what do they want it's in the oh down try again and
instead oh god i've been searching up for too long he told
me to calm down what do i
do i just like add someone to like wait to get invited yeah
we have to like wait we have to wait for brie to get in and
then she's gonna invite us in a vision.
She's going to invite me and then I'll invite you too.
Yunky.
Okay, accept.
Whoa.
Okay.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Invite a friend.
Oh, wait.
Do I have to add you guys?
Oh, no.
Guys.
Just add me.
There.
Did you add me?
I did it on party animals.
i did it yo one new game friend i said yo i have friends
thank you okay i sent a new mic to everyone okay Trevor got
in as well all right nice I'm here to slay where should you
slot Austin yeah the last is the beat up oh okay it's a beat
him up how come we couldn't find this lobby like what the
fuck I don't know oh it's because you didn't put the space
dash oh That makes sense.
I just flipped the jar and I couldn't find it.
I literally copied and pasted this.
So that's on there.
Well, yeah, because in the copy paste, it was...
Okay.
There's no space bar.
Oh.
Okay, so all we do is beat them up and then throw them out.
Are you guys good at throwing things?
Yeah.
I'm going in on the sauce.
All right.
Whoever dies first is a dead weight.
I'm knocking Doki Bird out.
What?
how could you do this to the captain how could you do this i
can't believe you've done this i can't believe it we're a
team i got a i got a bomb yeet that's not oh my god i didn't
get anybody oh wait wait what did i do get up get up get up
get up get up get up get up get up get up get up
there too wait how do i get up wait how do i oh it's so hard
when you're on the side i don't know how to get up this okay
it's up to you guys i'm out oh my donkey oh wait were you
the first one out no did it was did it was me did it was i
know i got i got my one i got my one i saw did it will
fucking walk off the conveyor.
Okay, I'm alive.
I'm alive.
No, no, no.
Oh my god, did she not did that happen?
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I'm throwing bombs.
I'm throwing bombs for you guys.
Uh oh.
Uh oh, never mind.
I might be dead.
Oh, no, no, no, no, this is the end.
This is, oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Guys, you're okay.
You're okay.
Lucky mo- I'm dead.
No!
Fru this is it!
This is on you!
This is- I'm- it's on Lillian!
This is all on you!
Okay goodbye.
Oh no.
Oh no!
I threw a banana.
That was their one.
They don't get another one.
Okay.
That was not okay.
I said Lillian.
No.
I'm a tie- I'm a tie- I missed.
Oh Brie!
Oh, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
No!
Uh oh, save me.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
What happened?
What happened from fire.
I thought this was your game.
Honestly, this is ping div.
Wait, you're dead first.
Yeah, this is ping div.
Oh!
Guys.
Alright guys, it's up to you.
Good luck.
guys when i heard i fell off and i'm the only one here now
i'm scared no you got ditto ditto's there oh my gosh oh are
you still alive yeah i don't know how to tell off this one
what do you mean he just had to keep jumping oh not that way
that's all no now you're the only one okay now i'm still
No, you're the only one.
They're all coming after me!
Hey, freaking kill them.
I can do it.
I don't know.
I don't know, guys.
Bumba.
You just got put in the fucking montage.
Oh my gosh.
This is the comeback.
I got knocked out instantly.
I don't know, guys.
Okay, you just punched me!
Sorry!
me go there i believe you took one die with you hell yeah
guys i can't get back up oh i can okay okay i'm gonna try
and kill him and i'm gonna take him down with me as well
yeah me too that's my plan now no oh my god he's glowing he
has a spinach okay he has the spinach i'm a little scared
okay oh oh jump Can I run?
Oh no!
Help me, thank you!
My hero academia.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
I'm trying to get back up.
How do you get back up?
Oh there you go.
Guys, I'm struggling.
If you jump kick, I think it's more of a chance to get up.
Oh really?
Okay.
That's good to know.
Oh no.
Oh, now there's three.
Oh, God.
I'm in.
Nice, Doki.
Oh, not nice anymore.
Not nice anymore.
I took it down with him.
Wow, how does that one hit not hit him off?
No, it's up to Ditto.
Wait, no, Ditto's dead.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah, I got Ditto.
Nice.
Hey, guys.
I think, look, I got my one.
I got my, guys, I got my one.
what were you guys doing who got their ones uh i got my five
i got you did not get five only two people fucking died in
that tired time you missed my clutch guardian angel save no
that was amazing i did yeah but you guys died regardless of
what does it matter listen what's more important in life
saving someone or killing someone that's what i thought well
if that person you're uh like going to jail anyway for
committing murder then like killing them is a better deal
you heard it here doki thinks murder is justifiable yeah if
you're murdering another murderer
if that person is if that person is about to commit multiple
murders and you murdered them before they commit multiple
murders then it's justifiable it's okay what if that person
was about what if that person was about to murder someone
who their child well what if that child grows up to commit
more murders and he was like a time traveler yeah i think
that's sound logic yeah that makes sense it should make
sense you heard it here doki said it's fine to murder
children so they don't no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no i'm saying that child and we should kill all the
children before they do anything therefore There will be no
problems The murderer was a time traveler Who knows the
future What that child is going to do It's like if you have
the power of time travel We travel You know how your logic
is flawed You know how your logic is flawed Because if
there's time travel It would already happen by now Yeah
because it's a paradox What if they created a multiverse So
that it drifts off to a separate multiverse?
Multiverse I love marble Yeah Someone pull the trigger I'm
going in deep Go go in the bomb Oh no I'm stuck I'll just
okay Go in.
Yeah.
Yeah, please.
Okay, then we have to...
Oh, they're here!
They're here!
That fucking bomb!
We gotta take them out!
No!
Hey, they're Chucky!
Oh, no!
What happened?
Oh, all of our stuff got destroyed.
No!
We gotta make sure we got...
I'm bringing the bombs over.
I'm just tracking them.
Just keep putting bombs in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get the bombs!
Throw them off!
No!
Throw him
off!
I made one bomb go off.
Don't worry, I dragged him down!
I dragged him down with me!
You're gonna die with me!
You're gonna die with me if it's the last thing I do!
Because at least I spawned back into my own base.
Oh my god.
I'm gone.
Go on the other side!
Get the bomb!
Go do it!
I'm back I'm back I'm bringing the bomb over Oh, that's me.
That's me that's me Take him over No, oh, no Oh, whatever
it's over he's over Yeah, all the others Oh, he got crushed
Yeah, I got put the bombs in put the bombs in We can't I'm
coming, I'm coming, I'm coming Oh, they sent two people over
It's okay, I'm back
Okay, do the lever Do the lever equipped
That's me, Ditto.
That's me.
Ditto, that's me.
Okay.
Hey, we're not doing too good.
I got bomb over.
Take the bomb and do it.
Oh,
he caught me the bomb.
I
got...
What did you guys do?
The bombs went off.
Guys, are we...
I think we're out.
I think we're out, guys.
Guys, we're not last.
We got one win.
Oh, I can't feed my kid!
Pokey's gonna kill my child!
Your future child!
Look, we're not last because we won one game.
Yeah.
We got that very first game and then we got high egos and
then we...
Failed miserably the rest of the tie.
We did the best we could.
For every winner there has to be a loser.
That's us.
Oh wait.
One to one.
Not GG's?
Yes.
One to one.
Don't eat!
Question mark?
Okay!
What do you mean?
These guys on the enemy team don't know what the fuck's
going on.
Don't!
I'm like Rumpo's still skin.
it's okay it's all about the friends we made along the way
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah i'm so excited i got in the future if
someone asked me to play i could just say oh yeah no we we
won some games on twitch rivals and i can lie even more
about my resume i'm so excited i got to play with the
legendary pussy slayer yeah yeah that's that's not here
Yeah, I got my warp scepter during all this.
That's a dub.
It's all right.
It's okay.
In the end, everybody gets money, guys.
Everybody.
Everybody gets money.
And that's what it's all about.
That's right.
Everybody wins something.
That's all that matters.
Exactly, guys.
Exactly.
Well, GG is everybody.
I think we're the first one out.
Okay, GG.
No, no, no.
There has been a team that lost every game and that's not
our team yeah but yeah but they still were in the
quarterfinals and we that's not our team there was a team
that lost every game but that wasn't us okay that's all that
matters that's all that matters ggs everybody ggs good luck
with the rest of your day guys see you
Alright, I had a great time.
I had a fun time with everyone.
It was honestly a huge blast playing with this team.
And oh yeah, I just had a fun time with this team as well.
There's been some...
I feel like on Twitch, things just get much more cursed in
general.
It's just the Twitch life.
Anyway, guys.
Um, it's okay.
We won our first game.
That's all that matters.
Guys, it's all about the adventures and the fun we had along
the whole way.
Hey, guys.
Uh, we do have another stream tonight, everybody.
Um, look, I was not the dead weight.
I, I did some clutch shit.
That's all I'm saying.
I pulled off my ones.
I did my ones, okay?
I defended so well during the trebuchet moment.
I fucking defended it so hard during the trebuchet and,
like, sent bombs over and everything.
Like, bro, come on.
I went full.
I fucking beat up the goalie.
And I scored, like, four goals.
Like...
all you did is punch the gold and that and i did my one i
did my one okay um and i sent the bombs over what they did
with the bombs was their job like i sent the bombs over they
had to finish the job
I did my 50% of the work.
I was sending bombs out.
I did, okay, that is not true, sure for at best, I was the
80% at that point.
Look, all I'm saying was that, no, no, no, no, no.
90% in that one game we won?
Huh, sure, poor?
Were you the 90% on that one game we won?
Where was the defending?
That was Bree's job!
Bree was the defender!
I was fucking sending bombs over!
I was carrying the bombs over and then I sent it over and
then I and then Bree had to do the defense for the other
bombs.
Mr. Lane Robbins was the carry.
What is this?
You're supposed to be my echo chamber.
What the fuck is this?
Anyway, guys, I had a great time with everybody.
I had a great time with my team.
For those who are new here, also thank you for the way away,
but I'm just about to end it today because we just finished
Twitch Rivals.
But anyway, guys, if you're new here, I usually stream on
the YouTubes.
So please check me um and that's where i usually stream i
should have a stream tonight um but i'll be speaking chinese
tonight on youtube uh with hiro um and uh she's fluent and
i'm not she actually knows how to read and write i don't
know either um anyway if you want to support me via other
means please check out my merch and uh if you want to know
when i stream on twitch i usually tweet out when i'm
streaming on twitch on twitter so please follow me on
twitter um what else what else what else also friday there's
gonna be a slight change in the schedule on friday i will be
playing marvel rivals because i got actually got invited to
uh to the alpha test i knew i knew tweeting that out was a
good idea um but yes a a person who knows the community
manager um reached out to me and said that they wanted they
were wanted to send me a code to try out marvel rivals on
friday and um um and they were impossibly i might be like i
don't know what let me read what they said they want to make
me like one of the official content creators for marvel
rivals i'm not sure yet uh but uh maybe i'll find out later
today because they said they want to give me more details
about it uh but yeah any guys as always everybody stay
hydrated pause check up and move around to get that blood
flowing and when you stay up for me head to bed because you
deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody and bye
guys bye